oui j'ai clairement dit le lien social
et déliter tout simplement parce qu on a
vu une des crédits qui ont été
majoritairement mise sur le centre ville
sur la ville centre des quartiers qui
ont été qui ont été délaissés
j'ai repris le budget 2010 9 le budget
2010 neuf c'était 4 millions pour le
centre ville c'était 615 millions pour
tous les autres quartiers
donc il ya vraiment un déséquilibre
autre élément il faut répondre aux
problématiques des chalonnaises et des
chalonnais nous avons parlé du taux de
chômage qui reste qu'on est important il
ya quand même beaucoup de personnes qui
sont éloignés de l'emploi
on a construit des immeubles à chalon
qui sont dix immeubles très cher un t2
dans le quartier de la sucrerie
c'est de ces cent cinquante mille euros
c'est beaucoup trop cher pour la
population chalonnaise
en même temps on a arrêté le programme
de rénovation urbaine dont qui venait en
aide aux plus précaires d'entre nous
donc est ce qu'il y a du fil oui on voit
très clairement effectivement que de
vielles se dessine chalon sur saône et
qu'on ne répond pas à la problématique
de la totalité des habitants de cette
ville
nous avons eu chaud à manger très envie
de vous de vous renvoyer dos à dos et
les uns et les autres tout simplement
parce que sur sous la mandature madame
de 2008 à 2014
certes il y avait un très gros effort de
fait au profit et j'ai presque envie de
dire au seul et unique profite d'un gain
des quartiers prioritaires de la ville
de chalon qui obérait absolument la
suite du développement équilibré de
chalon sur saône
et puis sur cette mandature la celle
inverse l'accent a été mis sur l'hyper
centre en gros sur les quais de saône et
à terme sur l'île saint laurent et je
crois que le vrai défi de la mandature à
venir ça va être de rééquilibrer
l'intégralité des investissements sur
cette ville parce qu'il y avait
énormément de demandes dans tous les
quartiers et quand on parle de quartier
c'est pas simplement les trois quartiers
prioritaires de la ville de chalon sur
saône
mais ce sont tous les quartiers de la
ville y compris ceux de la du centre
ville quand on parle de sécurité et
cetera je ferai quand même qu'on y pense
et il va falloir rééquilibrer tout ça re
donner de la lisibilité
parce que le lien se dévide pourquoi
parce que déchets le néant l'impression
d'être moins bien traités que d'autres
et c'est par cette lisibilité là et
c'est par le fait qu'ils vont pouvoir se
réapproprier tous ces dossiers là qu'on
va pouvoir recréer du lien
entre les uns et les autres de manière
équilibrée sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire on parlerait libre âge vers
équilibré aussi le propos bien sûr que
des investissements ont été consentis
sur le centre-ville le centre-ville
c'est le quartier le seul parti qui soit
commun à tous les chalonnais
on y va pour ses courses on y va pour
ses démarches administratives on y va
pour profiter les bords de la saône